[Music]
salvation indiana was your typical
midwestern american town the kind of
place where everyone knew each other
where everyone was comfortable leaving
their doors unlocked at night but there
was a sense of trust between neighbors
that you couldn't find in a more
populated area the kind of place where
word traveled fast and where people
talked about things that were improper
in hushed voices behind the backs of
others in salvation being an outsider or
deviating from the norm was akin to
complete isolation you either fit in or
you got out and if you didn't salvation
had its ways of making you conform to
the mold gossip organized stalking
efforts discrimination these small town
methods were often employed by the
town's inner circle to keep those who
they had a distaste for in check and
unfortunately this cliquish mentality
can be the norm when it comes to small
towns there's nothing anomalous about
the ugliness of human nature but
salvation did have its secrets the kind
that if brought to light would tear a
small town apart the kind that attracted
the attention of the us government's
unusual incidence unit a branch of the
federal bureau of investigation that
dealt with the paranormal and
supernatural the u.s government's answer
to the scp foundation between june 18th
and june 23
1976 the town of salvation indiana
underwent swaths of extreme anomalous
activity that affected the town's entire
population but was mainly centered
around salvation's high school
appropriately named well salvation high
school two uiu agents were dispatched to
salvation to assess the reports of
anomalous activity record it and of
course help cover it up this was one of
the few times the uiu got the jump on an
anomalous incident before a larger more
prominent organization such as the scp
foundation or the global occult
coalition but they got a company pizza
party for that one the operation went
smoothly with the agents using an early
amnestic labeled chemical 110 to wipe
the memories of the townsfolk after
interviewing them although in later
years study of chemical 110 would prove
it to be incredibly dangerous as the
amnestic was both toxic and had a
degrading damaging effect on human
memory centers between this and the
foundation's early amnestic models also
proving to be incredibly dangerous the
1970s were an interesting time indeed in
the field of supernatural cover-up
operations the timeline of events the
agents established depicted an eerie
scene it was only a few days but what
occurred was both horrifying and strange
on sunday night 10th grade students at
salvation high school reported hearing
what they described as someone trying to
speak under the ground while passing by
the school on their way home from a
church service one student reported it
to her mother who ignored it entirely on
monday an 11th grade student of
salvation high school claimed during gym
class that he could hear voices coming
from underneath the school's pool
several other students corroborated this
story when school officials came to
investigate they didn't find anything
unusual but the uiu agents found that
the lining of the bottom of the pool was
cracked on the same day several female
students reported seeing faceless things
instead of their own reflections in a
bathroom mirror they did not seem
bothered by this during lunch
announcements many students describe
being able to hear a third voice
alongside the two other students
speaking unintelligibly below the
broadcast curiously the agents found
that the pa room where the broadcast
originated from sat in a media center
near the pool on tuesday students
arriving at school noticed that the
indiana state flag was more than three
meters above the top of the flagpole
attached to nothing just floating the
american flag was not found and more
importantly the students claimed they
could see nine female figures hanging by
ropes from the flagpole who disappeared
immediately after being seen during a
biology class one student suddenly stood
up and rolled their eyes to the back of
their head they descended suddenly into
the floor and disappeared entirely
shortly after they reappeared above a
ceiling panel in the center of the room
no other students were able to identify
the student and several of their
classmates insisted that their actions
were just a joke the uiu agents were
unable to find proof of the student's
existence in salvation's enrollment
records similarly students described yet
another student they didn't recognize
walking the halls of the high school
they were unable to define any details
of their appearance save for one thing
that stood out they wore a purple
satchel with the word syncope
embroidered on the side a custodian
reported seeing something staring at him
standing at the bottom of the school
pool on wednesday the horror only sped
up as school staff noted that there was
a full two inches of water across all
levels of the school for whatever reason
the school's principal decided not to
close the school at 7 56 a.m the
entirety of the student body heard an
unknown voice whisper the word hello in
their right ear members of the school
band realized their instruments no
longer produced any sound but whenever
they played they reported seeing a small
black human-shaped entity flickering in
and out of view in the corner of the
room facing the wall one student saw a
dark figure walking up and away from the
school through the air at an impossible
angle eventually the figure disappeared
from her sight and was never seen again
no other student addressed this on
thursday a student in gym class avoided
a dodgeball as it phased through his
body he sunk into the floor screaming
for help nobody who noticed seemed
motivated enough to help him the entire
school shifted roughly one foot off of
its foundations at 11am the vice
principal who was sent to inspect the
building's integrity describes seeing
something small with too many faces
grinning at him from underneath the
building before the school inexplicably
resettled back to its original position
the boys locker rooms disappeared and
were replaced with what witnesses
described as something that screamed
they were unable to provide any details
as students left for the day they saw
nine young women hanging in the air
tilted forward at an angle above the
school's parking lot they could be
silently mouthing words and their
appearances were described by witnesses
as ugly and unremarkable they vanished
and again the majority of the town
residents reported hearing a child's
voice say the word hello below them upon
the figure's disappearance a panic
ensued as town officials had no
explanation for these events salvation's
principal made the call to close the
school on friday however when friday
morning arrived the entire student body
showed up for school the building was
locked so the students simply waited
outside to be let in no individuals
could describe why they were there there
was a knock on a window and the students
saw a small black entity standing
outside of a second-story classroom an
entity phased in and out of the school's
windows over and over until suddenly
disappearing after this the front door
unlocked itself and the mass gathering
of students entered the building however
what they found was unlike the small
school they had come to know over the
years inside salvation high school was
transformed into a non-euclidean space
meaning that reality didn't work inside
it the way it should hallways that led
right instead led downward stairs that
went up instead curved left as the
students moved through the school they
couldn't help but feel like they were
always moving down
lower and lower some heard whispers
others heard drums in the distance as
they approached the basement they saw a
massive stone archway suddenly the
students shifted encasing the entire
group in rock and earth for 20 seconds
after this brief suffocating torture
ended the students reappeared back in
the school except this time every one of
them reported being the only one in the
building they described the experience
wandering the building alone before
coming to what they called a doorway
below a doorway and ended up inside a
small sub-basement room there they saw
three mysterious visions a woman
crouched over a body of water surrounded
and covered in blood a farmhouse and a
group of trees that were burning nine
white humanoid figures floating in the
air overhead a weeping woman digging in
a field until her hands began to rot and
fall apart when these visions subsided
the black entity reappeared again it
whispered hello and the group of
students were suddenly surrounded by
nine screaming female figures after this
the students reappeared inside their own
homes it was at this point that the uiu
began to enter the town to distribute
amnestics to the subjects more anomalous
activity was recorded in rapid
succession bodies hanging in the sky
water taps leaking human hair and mucus
instead of water individuals reported
that their facial features had
disappeared entirely others reported
seeing faceless creatures in the town
the black entity frantically appearing
and reappearing in rapid succession
throughout the town even a weeping young
woman running back into the school's
building who witnesses lost after she
entered the school's basement the
cover-up effort was brutal but it worked
the town's people of salvation were
convinced that they saw hallucinations
as a result of toxic gases blown south
from a factory up north but what was the
connection between all the phenomena
nine faceless female entities water and
blood something that literally upsets
the entire foundation of salvation high
school a small black entity adults in
the town ignoring the things their
children saw and acting indifferent
toward them all this sounds a lot like a
dirty dark secret being unearthed in the
town of salvation something people would
rather turn a blind eye to and ignore
but they couldn't because the terror was
only getting started a week after these
events occurred contractors assessing
the damage to the school discovered the
sub-basement room where the students had
various visions of anomalous entities
behind it was the entrance that led to
the large stone archway this
anti-chamber was discovered after one of
the members of the contracting team
slipped and fell beneath a collapsed
section of wall and floor that led to
the massive area underneath the school
the contracting team attempted to
extract them but they did not succeed
their disappearance caught the attention
of the scp foundation who assessed the
school and deemed the area beneath the
school to be anomalous as the building's
architecture should not be able to
accommodate the size of the area it was
designated scp-3935
and as the foundation began
investigating it they were determined to
uncover the truth of what really was
occurring in salvation indiana while
exploring scp-3935
they came across the stone archway a
piece of architecture whose origins are
unknown
inscribed on the arch was a phrase that
read way below winds deeper
longer
unspeakable its patterns laid the lost
forever damned to wander
this thing a quiet madness made after
the initial establishment of scp-3935
as an anomalous location the foundation
poured deeper into salvation's mystery
and came across the documents created by
the uiu agents the foundation being much
more thorough in their containment
methods than the uiu decided that the
small town of 1400 people was easy
enough to relocate entirely and the
entire area could be condemned feeding
into the excuse of a hazardous waste
facility nearby leaking noxious gases
into the town's water and air supply
with the townsfolk successfully
relocated salvation was quarantined and
cut off from the rest of the world roads
were removed and rerouted and foundation
personnel turned over any trespassers to
local authorities salvation high school
became a hub for foundation researchers
studying
scp-3935 and the events that occurred in
the town and the building was heavily
guarded when not in use by the
organization the initial exploration
attempt into
scp-3935 was conducted by a team of
foundation agents shortly after members
of the contracting team were lost there
was a slight hope they could be
recovered and the effort was dubbed a
search and rescue mission three agents
ellis porter and haskell were tasked
with entering scp-3935
all equipped with recording equipment
and a shoulder-mounted lamp system they
entered a cramped narrow space beyond
the archway where the subterranean stone
walls got tighter and tighter and the
air felt stuffy and uneasy on the walls
images resembling a child's drawings
were carved into the rock as the teams
continued to push through the rock
tunnel they found it difficult to
breathe the walls were getting narrower
too close for comfort suddenly porter's
voice cut out and his camera feed went
black when it came back it appeared to
be looking up at two sources of light
most likely the other two agent's lamps
as porter fell from a great distance his
screaming was heard on both the cameras
and by the other agents but they
couldn't figure out where he was
and haskell began to panic moving faster
and attempting to struggle forward the
rock tunnel was so tight so constraining
that they were unable to move more than
a few steps in a second after a short
period of time both men fell forward
into a larger open space as they
searched for porter who wasn't behind
them they came to the conclusion that he
must have fallen into a ravine or
slipped beneath the rocks there was no
other explanation for how he disappeared
so suddenly but their talk was cut short
when they realized what was in front of
them they hadn't noticed it at first but
when they turned their lamps forward
they noticed a gigantic structure
seemingly carved out of stone it
resembled salvation high school
almost perfectly the main entrance was
visible and the windows too a stone
replica of the school hidden in this
massive underground area the agents
couldn't believe it there was a thick
layer of fog in front of them but they
could make out a narrow stone bridge
that extended across a large chasm
leading to the stone replica of the
school as they examined further they
noticed that underneath the school was
another model of the school and under
that one was another it went on
indefinitely extending deeper and deeper
into the ground in the direction that
all things in salvation seemed to go
down
on the other side of the bridge hanging
mid-air were nine female entities their
faces obscured by long white hair the
two agents stood still in fear after a
short time the figures appeared 10
meters backwards and then another 10 and
then they appeared right in front of the
door of the stone school structure
slowly they lifted their heads revealing
their featureless faces to the agents
who recoiled in fear after that they
disappeared the two agents debated going
back for reinforcements but they pushed
onward after hearing the sudden sound of
many voices speaking in hushed tones in
the distance it could have been the lost
contractors or their lost man porter
they entered the stone school and began
searching inside they couldn't make
heads or tails of the architecture as
they ran down the hallways following the
sound of the voices they noticed that
the halls seemed to stretch on forever
but they didn't seem to notice the
watching featureless faces who observed
the agents from the window panes in the
doorways as the agents came to the
auditorium doorway agent haskell let out
a screen and his voice recorder
disconnected at this point what occurred
became nearly impossible to make out on
the foundation's recording the voices
grew louder haskell's camera shifted
perspective to the floor nine female
entities appeared around agent ellis
contorting their bodies into impossible
positions haskell ran but the entities
pursued him he screamed for help
eventually the figures hung in the air
unmoving haskell slowed down two and
slowly turned around coming face to face
with a small black humanoid entity
sitting upside down on the ceiling of
the hallway it whispered one word hello
the feed cut out to the choppy sounds of
audio distortion a snapping noise was
heard and then silence and then all
three agents feeds were turned for the
duration of the exploration recording
haskell ellis and porter lost their
minds in the depths of scp-3935
in between periods of silence they
laughed screamed and shouted
incoherently rambling on about how dark
it is and how they can't go down any
further below where it goes on forever
where they can be part of the nine be a
part of salvation where they can fall
forever and after that
silence the feed was cut out completely
and neither the trio nor the contractors
were ever recovered after this failed
horrifying exploration attempt more
anomalous activity occurred in the town
during the foundation's occupation
sightings of the nine faceless entities
in the streets and the trees an agent
who saw the black figure constantly in
his peripheral vision sounds coming from
a grove of trees near the school which
led to a cabin and nine corpses of
former salvation high school students in
the backyard but before they could
investigate the female entities appeared
once more and they were unable to locate
the grove again the foundation's
investigation of salvation continued
through the decades interviewing former
staff members of the school and
residents they were trying to piece
together any semblance of a coherent
story to find a way to connect all these
dissonant elements into something
understandable the black figure the
corpses the buried secrets and the nine
female entities how did it all connect
to the school in 2002 a foundation agent
interviewed mrs fletcher an english
teacher at salvation high school during
the period of anomalous activity in
1976.
the interview started out ordinarily
enough fletcher in her old age couldn't
remember much she remembered the town
was quiet with a tight-knit community
they didn't even need a police force
because there was so little crime she
remembered students would go into the
woods and chase ghosts or claimed they
saw things but it was never anything too
strange but as fletcher continued to
talk she let her mind wander more and
more she recounted how there was a
disappearance at the high school a girl
who was last seen by the school's pool
the town assumed she ran away after all
there were some individuals who held
strong opinions in salvation the kind of
opinions that didn't sit right with some
of the younger residents the church was
important in salvation nearly everyone
went fletcher opened up some more there
was a scandal she recalled a teenage
girl on the school cheer team who ended
up pregnant out of wedlock she couldn't
recall her name or what she looked like
but she remembered the town's inner
circle was in an uproar about it she
didn't want them to know she didn't want
anyone to know it was a secret she could
barely keep from spreading it must have
been destroying her fletcher explained
she couldn't remember much about the
girl but she did remember that the girl
would always say hello to her too many
times in fact eventually the girl was
found hanging in the woods right outside
of a log cabin they found a note in her
hand which contained a drawing of a
building that resembled the high school
and on its back the repetition of the
same word over and over again but
fletcher couldn't recall what the word
was the foundation agent was about to
close the interview out but he had one
last thing to ask he produced a picture
of the unidentified nine female figures
that were haunting the town and showed
it to fletcher she became noticeably
pale and short of breath do you know
anything about this mrs fletcher the
agent said she collected herself and
examined the image as best as she could
her hand's shaking oh yeah
yes i do
those are um
the cheerleaders they were uh well
let me think there were ten of them
though i think unless something happened
to one of them there were definitely ten
the foundation didn't have to ask what
happened to the tenth now go check out
scp-1337 the hitchhiker and revenge of
d-class ghosts scp-4973
dead men walking for more ominous
hauntings that keep the horrors of the
past alive and well